I put on a Kylie Jenner liquid lipstick
for this we need you all to shut up and
watch no my face doesn't match my hands
it's like a beauty guru say about
filling in your eyebrows your hands and
your face color supposed to be
step-siblings not twins hi my name is
grace Helbig do don't know now you know
your life is different now
oh welcome to another sponsored video
yeah
last time I didn't have a fresh
sponsored video I made jokes in that
video about hoping they would like it to
give me a longer-term brand deal and you
know what if she didn't even with this
dirtiest mouth you know what's really
fulfilling about moving in the privacy
of your own home true love and creating
a brand sponsored video with a brand
that you genuinely really enjoy and have
use for that then paying you to tell
other people why they should use it I
didn't wink because that's a lie I went
because I'm being coy I'm trying out
different things guys doing very so well
in 2014 right now guys you're gonna love
these talking points you're gonna love
these ad reads because I've been really
working on my acting I didn't really
know the sincerity you feel confused in
your kitchen you feel fed up making food
you go
but I basically everything well then I
have a brand for you know hello fresh
makes conquering the kitchen easier with
simple already pre-planned meals that
you can make at home if you have a fresh
in the past because I just love it I am
a person that doesn't organize her
thoughts well if you haven't noticed
hello fresh is basically like a food
meal delivery service and they give you
three different meals you can customize
it to however your dietary restrictions
are hey give you all the prepackaged
ingredients so you can cook at your home
they basically trick you into thinking
that you can cook it's like when people
buy their children those like plastic
kitchen sets and they're like oh I love
you making plastic eggs no mom not so
great
she's just feeding your child ice in a
more adult way hello freshers it can you
the opportunity to imagine how good you
are at cooking they give you these
recipe cards that have like six steps
with photos visual learners unite can
you be visually dyslexic because if you
are you might need a buddy to help you
with this I'm gonna make one with you
and we're just gonna sit and chat and
talk what should we call this series
like sweat tears the grace Helbig
cooking show leave me some options down
below cook one of these
fresh milk or a chat about life and
things and stuff in my kitchen that I
claimed solely so that you would judge
the natural scum state in which I
operate on a regular basis Oh am i into
vici is that my good thing so the meals
they sent me this week are the Juicy
Lucy burger what a tease
siggi balsamic pork whoa and the maple
and mustard glazed pork chops which one
should I choose this is like
Bandersnatch except you don't actually
have a choice I choose I'm also making
this before I have to go to therapy
actual therapy you know they say cooking
is therapy but then you know what this
actual therapy therapy in like an hour
and so these meals are supposed to be
really easy to make in like under an
hour's ish time and if I get really
stressed out about this I have something
to talk about in therapy
what meal says I'm most adult capable
and I don't really need therapy I'm just
doing it you know to maintain yes the
maple one mustard glazed pork chops I
agree no one that makes themselves maple
and mustard glazed pork chops at 12:30
p.m. on a Tuesday afternoon is chef just
like David Letterman slam everything
comes in this beautiful little package
that's all talking point get out of that
recipe get out of that recipe right and
start cooking outside your comfort zone
with new and delicious recipes I made a
choice to try and cry yet to show you
how much it impacted me this brandy
how's my acting if you don't want to
spend money on that like holistic
Chinese all relaxation things just get
some teeny-tiny russet potatoes look how
relaxing this is no braise in my eyes
there's been true dur in my eye
you didn't say the right Pascoe get out
of my eye [ __ ] guys i watch all of
queer I and I'm very sad I feel like
there's now been a death in my family
because it's gone I'm feeling a sense of
grief and loss why did I do that to
myself why didn't I pace myself
what we had to preheat the oven to 450
degrees
wash and dry roll produce and cut
potatoes into wedges
I hate showering personally hate
showering
it's okay I love hellofresh that's
enough Oh fight me on that not one of
your body exponent mine I like my
potatoes like I'm like my summer sandals
half inch thick wedges oh boy I
shouldn't be allowed to have knives also
watched abducted in plain sight it's a
documentary that's about exactly what
the title says and it stressed me though
yeah okay potatoes have been cut now we
need to take the time take the time Yeah
right on the fourth of an ounce we
definitely know what 1/4 of an ounce is
that's four ounces well chop it up a
little bit
Oh God she's like a ballerina in the
kitchen said no one baking sheet oh they
just put sprigs of thyme on I already
[ __ ] up helping you were on step 1 and
you didn't look at the pictures and the
pictures are what they gave you for
reference like I said cooking is like
really fluid and artistic ASMR olive oil
on and we put our time salt and pepper
so and then we toss this all together
ready party party Cancun spring break
1999 sorry I had to stop hacking into
the mainframe so I could put my potatoes
in the oven for 25 minutes or until
they're crisp Oh
step one officially done how can we shop
step two gonna make her glaze and step
see now we're gonna make our epic I'm a
character like a 90s sitcom and they're
opening credit sequence you guys
children show okay we're gonna make our
glaze I need more time leaves we need to
strip another one and a half teaspoons
of thyme leaves you sexy music with
awesome
whoa I'm gonna get flagged and taken off
of you too
they're roughly chopped my camera
stopped because exactly like last time
I'm talking too much and not doing
enough I'm running out of time before
have to go to therapy and talk about why
suddenly I'm stressed but fulfilled for
making my own delicious meal half the
lemon and cook what happened to wedges
in a small bowl she little we stir
together at the time two tablespoons of
maple syrup hmm two tablespoons two
tablespoons of Dijon mustard Oh
pure sex and stock concentrate oh look
how sexy cooking is oh that's got an
odor to it
Oh buddy now we mix this I'm gonna mix
it with this cute tiny whisk because I
just you know I'm cute and I'm a whisk
very consistent we made our glaze I
think now he seasoned our pork again I'm
sorry if you are vegetarian they do have
vegetarian options let me double check
that for sure yes they have a classic
veggie and a family plan I'm always
right never wrong
we're gonna season our pork with one
teaspoon of this spice blend that they
sent they sent way more than we need to
so hey you can save this for later if
you really like it add some salt and
pepper we're gonna put it in a large pan
over medium-high heat with some oil in
it and we're gonna cook three to four
minutes each side
porks in the pan a child euphemism
cooking three to four minutes on each
side this is until their desired
doneness can you imagine if that was
what reality star said when they got in
fight instead of saying I'm done they
just go I've reached my desired doneness
take my mic pack I've reached my desired
doneness
I'm desired Lee done after they have
reached just shy of their desired
doneness we're gonna pour our maple
syrup glazed all over them and cook for
about one minute and then we're gonna
remove them from the pan and stir it a
squeeze or two of lemon juice okay I
forgot to be talking to you
how are your regrets going a lot of
people like to focus on goals I like to
focus on like we're dressed for me of
those we gotta go it's got a couple less
than last time
good for you got a couple more go frito
but the humping a cat thing right
that was a time let me shake my potatoes
nope I've never been good at waiting or
making small talk but there's one trick
to making small talk tomorrow there's
actually there's more talking points
okay okay watch this hello freshers now
$6.99 for serving and you can get
started with eight free meals that's $80
off your first month if you go to hello
fresh calm and use the code class Helbig
abies let's check our pork okay we're
gonna put the maple glaze in now we're
gonna let it kind of cook for like a
minute okay okay okay forget always stir
in a squeeze of lemon juice okay then we
remove the pan from the heat now time to
toss the salad cooking is so sexual the
mixed greens what do you call the
vlogbrothers when someone can't tell
them apart mixed greens lame cranberries
and sunflower seeds a tablespoon of
olive oil some lemon juice and salt
pepper and now we toss this out I am
perpetually a 13 year old boy eight free
bills a dollars off your first month of
hellofresh you could toss salads just
like grease Oh can't wait to go to
therapy my potato
look at these ow time to plate this up
let's do it um what this looks insane
okay let's get some Beauty shots on this
[ __ ]
[Music]
just try to tell me that they don't look
completely ridiculously similar we did
we did that we did that I have to leave
her there I've been like five minutes so
we did this also something that makes a
lunch like this for themselves on a
Tuesday afternoon doesn't need therapy
they're just like go to therapy because
they're preventive self-care now I'm
gonna die have to eat it right oh yeah
duh don't we calm slash edu slash me oh
no oh no we made something really good
again that's gonna give us a false sense
of confidence no we're gonna believe we
can do anything now don't worry we'll go
to therapy will talk about Oliver just
look at knockdown effect I'm mad that I
was able to accomplish this I do guys
read here with me along the way
hope you like this video just a blink
and brandy Lee yeah do I have any shame
in that game no did I make a delicious
meal yeah do I hope that you try this on
your own
yeah have I lost my entire train of
thought I'm just saying words that I
don't know make full sentences yeah if
you guys like this video give it a
thumbs up don't get subscribe to this
YouTube channel I make videos other than
that I don't know oh how could you be
shopping now and then that angle weird
to see me doing this look like slow
dancing